the hype trains about to come into the
station near west yes this is actually a
really interesting bit because even
though it's a behemoth and yes it's
designed to change the game it really
depends on how you use it if you don't
use it correctly then you could actually
leave yourself more vulnerable it could
go very quickly indeed and then you've
lost your chance to sort of change the
tide of the battle and let's let's go
down that route cheeks we're going to
see an action very very soon the point
is it doesn't really get to the capture
points does it only really goes by one
it has an effect on a second it does do
damages no disputing that here comes the
train now and yes it is on rails for
anyone else out there who wants to make
a joke about that no is on Rails and it
features six different seats plenty of
cannons on the side it's actually got an
anti air cannon as well so it is
extremely powerful not only two ground
units but people up in the sky really do
need to pay attention as well now
speaking of up in the sky though there
has to be accounted this as you said
there are ways to play around these
behemoths because we saw in that first
map people were kind of unsure how to
deal with it the first time then you see
that everyone coming together taking it
down and working through it how do you
deal with that train well one of the
things that you can do is as an infantry
unit obviously as i said the assault
player does have access to some
explosives but in in my own sort of
experience of looking at the games that
we've seen players in sort of planes are
going to be the best ones to sort of
their eyes and try yeah eyes in the sky
really you've got people in the bombers
and they're the ones who can deal a
massive amount of damage if they lay
down a carpet of bombs on top of that
train they're going to do a massive
amount of damage well speaking of it you
highlighted corny line HD is well the
players you wanted to watch for this
ability he's already eyeing up that
train he knows what he wants out of this
one definitely but just so we can see
here this is a really good shot just the
scale of the map as well it's absolutely
massive it is a huge map you can see the
objective off in the middle that he's
taking some serious damage but he's
going to come in I think for another
stray front if oh he's going for the
repair and feels like you're safe enough
to do that
but I think he's probably going to come
in for another strafing run on that on
that train and this is the beauty of
battlefield as well it's not just about
your infantry it's up in the air top in
the skies we're seeing those dog fights
coming through and now here comes that
run again the hit-and-run pony lion a
tree needs to back Alice he's got to be
careful he is taking fire as well
they're not laying him just get away
with this and all the armored train took
him out completely wow that really does
show the power of of that train there
that's something that you do have to
note though is that people up in the
planes may be the best person the best
people to try and take this thing out
but you leave yourself extremely exposed
to everything else up there as well
because you're concentrating on
something on the ground not the other
plane that's now behind you shooting at
you and also let's let's bear in mind
because a lot of people get nervous
about this idea how's that gonna work is
it balances not keep your eyes on the
tickets they haven't want drastically in
one favor it's more even the scoreboard
it's meant to be able to turn the tide
of the war almost and we've got a little
bit of that he was like a wolf an
awesome pistol shot you're gonna get
punished there the m18 trench gun is
gonna deal with you very swiftly he
tried they tried to go for like a sneaky
melee kill but it didn't quite pay off
and you know what happens to me all the
time you try and go for it and the
person turns round at the last minute of
course they're the one standing there
with a fully automatic weapon whilst
you've got a bolt action rifle so and
that again is the beauty of battlefield
it's the rock-paper-scissors mechanic
everything has a counter if you're going
in for the melee you better be aware
that that person could turn round at any
moment and you've left yourself
extremely vulnerable who have we got
here this is drifter he's taking the
tank into perhaps a uncharted territory
into a more infantry part of the map but
of course he's putting a lot of power
behind those infantry units there yeah
that's certainly gonna do some great
damage but already you can still find
this infantry battle going on these
buildings allow for perfect cover the
map however does change the cover it
just completely removes itself
throughout this battle and again mazi
here on the ground to the right
side you can see the craters that have
been formed in the ground that could
have been from a dumb fire rocket from
the plane it could have been it could
have been the the anti-tank grenade
there are so many things that you need
to be aware of in this game and terrain
defamation is one of them yet suddenly
you might be able to use that as cover
but on other occasions and most likely
that cover has just been taken away yeah
it's interesting to note that that train
was still going at that point because
the match has moved on a fair bit but
the train was still there plucking away
and look at where the flags have been
captive let's keep that in mind only to
a secure one for each team so at the
moment it's actually fairly even both
teams going for different jacket both
running at the same time you are seeing
the covering fire going down the
suppression coming into the place that
flag is so contested right now that
doing whatever they can and that's what
a range you don't have the best of luck
with that sort of weaponry and why
you're not going on much more likely to
do that that's this accident i'm not
sure why i don't know a little backflip
and go well
you